was macht nichts ich sag einfach nur
hallo jetzt brauche ich die kamera war
wegen dokumentation hast du glaubst du
mir irgendwas vor
ich habe alle deine antrat leute ich
kann gar nicht lange reden ich habe den
ganzen tag schon merger sub hat ich bin
ultra im stress das könnt euch nicht
vorstellen ich würde die ganze nacht
durch verpacken aber egal alles für euch
deswegen heute ein relativ kurzes video
aber ich hab ne geile idee ich bin
gerade auf der toilette und rät bisschen
weiser bei max da drüben gerade aufnimmt
und er hat heute schon video aufgenommen
und dafür dass hier eingesetzt wie du
und ich dachte mir was kaum so machen
man kann es sich eigentlich nur ins
gesicht hauen vernünftiger mensch ist
deswegen machen wir es folgen getränken
max und zwar gehen wir mit biologen auf
der hand ins zimmer während ärger in
minecraft mauz mit luca aufnimmt gehen
zu ihm hin sagen heimat dass ich habe
einfach gesagt zum beispiel das gerächt
haben oder nicht
bad direkt in die fresse das machen wir
zwingen sagt er ist direkt im zimmer
nebenan müssen leise sein ich muss mich
schon auf die hand und leute sowie dafür
dass ich so fertig aussehen des
videospiel kommt wie gesagt heute mega
merchandise stress ich denke versteht es
einfach dieses ekligen eklige zeug und
nehmen uns in die linke hand gibt
[Applaus]
hier vorne schön schön verteilt ihr ist
der schwerpunkt mit dem man trifft mit
dem den griff man muss richtig so
ich weiß nicht wieder aufnehmen will
aber ich glaube ich finde so hier
übrigens noch die ganzen kissen vom
management als sie das
da steht noch mega vier um das ganze
wird heute noch verpackte heimat
sebastian kommt gerade für doku wieder
ungeniert polzin ralph schiller theater
wie ist jetzt das geht ab bis jetzt
dabei seien ja abonniert alle sp nicht
ich sage einfach nur hallo
jetzt brauche ich die kamera bewegen
dokumentation irgendwas vor
[Musik]
er hat mir einfach gerade eine komplette
hand ins gesicht gefasst der kopfhörer
diese tust du bist mir ganze störe es
ist was ich mache teile und
kanalarbeiter auch ich komme gleich
wieder ich muss mir nun ist münchen
freut euch nicht darüber sondern vor
allen dingen in meinem video wer wollte
wie die für mich auch genau wurde ich so
great wheel ist jetzt wieder genau die
gleiche system in geiselhaft das recht
wie du von meinen die rückstände ist
richtig an sozial nicht auslasten bevor
bei mir wird immer so was eine aufnahme
machte hatte hand sei plötzlich
klatschen ich würde so die stellen
verteilt hätte alles im auge
ich will einfach ein viel zu hohes
risiko fraser zuverlässigkeit sebastian
anhalt folge struggled auch ein video
aufzugeben heute deshalb bin ich erstmal
nicht sauer sollte wenn ihr zuhause noch
irgendwas dringlich machen müsst dann
heute einfach nicht mein bruder seif ins
gesichts immer eine schlechte idee
max ganz gut genommen abonnierte max ist
erste ring beschreibung hat er nicht
hätte ich schon den ganzen tag wie
überall kleben so lange sauber gemacht
haben ein video weißwasser schlimmste
ist was es trocknet die haut so aus mein
ganzes gesicht war ganz so trocken nicht
das ipad laufen jetzt habe ich es wieder
ja ich muss jetzt schnell weiter auf dem
rhein abonniert eine magd
sauber gemacht dass ihr nur sitzt und
kälte